yeah welcome to this video and let's go
Knight f3 is the slimming she livin she
and I'm failing miserably puerto rico
this actually would have been my guess
if you can believe that or not but ok so
um let's see if this alien let's just
play it in them and the testosterone
fashion with d for time enough okay so
what now usually they say that you
shouldn't play a 3 in this kind of
opening hmm can i play this I'm not sure
we should be for a bit of an annoyance
but maybe I can take and play Queen d4
okay so then maybe I managed to set up
this set up with Queen f3 and long
castles g4 and so on it's taking its
time as well this is how is a good sign
if I'm in an opening that I really don't
know um okay um he's thinking or he's
intending to play this Bishop g4 but the
way this is a big deal i can i can take
here right Bishop g4 I've got Queen g3 I
thought this would be good isn't this
good using this pen so pretty pretty
standard motif in this position not this
but this this idea um pinning the Queen
and taking g7 selves if you place a move
like Bishop d6 um there's some
possibilities too I can just take 27
probably ya black ass playing with fire
here because he really is behind the
development okay no this is the kind of
move you you really don't want to play
okay so 95 him is the the normal
response
how to continue just bishops III or is
there some bottom with Bishop Bishop b6
is a very direct move
hmm yeah should be six is probably good
also it's not not it's directed probably
good which 97's as a big threat and if
it takes Knight takes the mafookas
heaven is just really atrocious and
there's also night c 8 25 coming and
this is directly winning even probably
this wedding bouquet seven justjust
night x + 25 / rookie seven not takes
Queen takes Queen d5 check-up should be
seven maybe chem lab should be seven but
it looks okay so he's giving up giving
up the the rook for the moon but I don't
think I am I really want to take it he
doesn't he doesn't have a moose actually
you should see four or something or is
there a director when Queen d3 we should
be settlement come on let's develop a
piece this is probably a simple and good
look everyone
yeah if everything else fails I can
still take the rook and he needs to
recapture and put the Queen in the
corner so how to believe that you would
be able to defend this still
hmm
maybe age four and age five he cannot
move this is the problem are this year
ok we now know I take it so yeah I need
to enter with the Queen somehow
um this this way i can play gphone yes
the probably good
Queen f3 to h5 or queen h2 is even
better maybe I know
gphone needs to display that
should be f6 ship takes bishop f7
winning the Queen
and I didn't really pay attention to the
clock of the Sun might be the big issue
at the end check check
check
you know it's its eyes getting the edge
porn this is unlucky hi morning yeah
I've got a fairly nicely coordinated
position this helps a bit but still 19
seconds
check-check
I is very slow talking claim
black 45 you know and it's even a window
I can stop the porn and Edwin d5 but
okay I certainly Adam made somewhere I
really failed to win this with mate yeah
I don't know maybe this age age four and
stuff was 23 yeah of course I have I
didn't really see Queen d3 to d5 this is
a problem very easy actually 2325 this
is I mean probably winning as well it's
plus 6 according to come but it's not
meeting yeah thanks for watching